underground in the city of mikaliv is a
bunker that's now a children's ward
drip feeds and medication are
administered among the gloomy basement
pipework
[Music]
oxana's done the best to brighten things
up for her two sons nikita and artem
whose toys reflect the battle above
she last spoke to her husband four days
ago he is among some of the last
fighters holding out in the pummeled
city of mariupol
m
the children here are afraid to go above
ground medics don't want us to locate
this place fearing it would make it a
target
a nearby hospital is one of more than
300 in ukraine that has been shelled
which is a war crime here they've
treated 24 children for conflict wounds
two of them have died
yes
[Music]
but people in mikolai still have to
venture out there's been no running
water in the city for six days
at a mobile supply tanker we meet a man
recovering from a shrapnel wound whose
dog was killed in a blast
in a nearby park blood-stained ground
and a discarded cap is the only clue to
horror that rained down on civilians
outside this church on friday local
authorities say several blasts killed
five people and injured fifteen
mikolaiv has held off the russians but
it is still terrorized by them with
missiles and artillery fire and walking
around the city you just pray that
you're not in the wrong place at the
wrong time
they pray two for their soldiers for
their dead
and more than anything for an end to
this war
jason farrell sky news nick alive
you